(pleasant mallet percussion music)
- [Alexander] The coronavirus
has upended the world
of higher education.
In March, students were
abruptly sent home,
classes were moved online.
Now, as campuses across
the country sit empty,
administrators are scrambling
to prepare for what comes next.
- In many ways, the attack
that COVID represents
to higher education is a
really straightforward assault
on the bottom line.
- The financial challenges are severe.
I mean, I won't kid you,
they're profoundly challenging.
- There will be more bankruptcies,
more business failures,
more need to federal and state bailouts.
- [Alexander] The pandemic
has thrown the budgets
of public and private
colleges into turmoil.
Since the lockdowns went into effect,
they have seen their revenues
drop and their expenses climb.
- And I think, yeah, more
than belt-tightening,
this may be something like
reconstructive surgery
if not actually thoracic surgery.
- [Alexander] With all
education now virtual,
e-learning is having a moment.
When students were sent home mid-semester,
American higher ed began
what was essentially
a nationwide experiment.
In the space of three weeks,
all learning was moved from
the classroom to the internet.
This has accelerated the
trend towards online education
and raised more fundamental questions
about the value of a college degree.
- College students
suing Drexel University,
the University of Miami and others
saying online learning is no replacement
for a bricks and mortar
on-campus experience.
- What will be the
lasting legacy of COVID-19
for higher education?
Could this virus lead to a wave
of college and university closures?
Will the classroom we
once knew gradually return
or could COVID permanently
transform how we learn?
- Hello.
- Hey, Bryan.
To help answer these questions,
I spoke to Bryan Alexander,
a higher education futurist.
As his title suggest,
Alexander spends a lot of time
contemplating what might happen
in the higher education space.
In a passage included in his 2020 book,
Alexander suggested the possibility
of a global pandemic
transforming the industry.
- I wrote the chapter in 2018, 2019,
and I'm afraid it is chillingly prescient.
- [Alexander] But how do you
imagine a post-COVID future
when so little is known
about COVID itself?
With so much uncertainty
surrounding the pandemic,
Alexander believes it's
impossible to divine
any one outcome.
Instead he sees three potential paths
for the future of higher education.
- One is that we could be
in the middle of a short plague,
that is, something which
burns out relatively quickly,
that perhaps a month from now,
we are very, very far
down the downhill side
and that, come August and September,
we'll be in good shape and
colleges and universities
can open their physical doors
to welcome face-to-face students again.
A second possibility is that the pandemic
will extend through December into 2021.
In that case, then we have to
think about higher education
being virtual throughout
the entire fall semester.
- [Alexander] Recently,
the California State University system
announced that it would be canceling
most in-person classes in the fall
and will instead hold them online.
This is significant because
the Cal State system
is the largest four-year
university system in the country.
The system is also one of the
most diverse in the country,
with 1/3 of undergraduates
the first in their families
to attend college.
One of those is Ana Ruth Bertolazzi,
a senior at San Francisco
State University.
- As a single parent, my
son, he's a seventh-grader,
soon now close to be eighth-grader,
it was a challenge.
- [Alexander] Like many students,
one challenge Ana has
faced are class disruptions
due to a slow internet connection.
- There are moments
when, if I ask a question
to my Zoom class professor,
either my voice is not even
projecting or it stops.
- [Alexander] Students like
Ana would also be impacted
by Alexander's third forecast.
- A third possibility is that,
instead of having a simple
pandemic, short or long,
that we'll have something more complicated
with multiple waves.
For academia, I dub this the toggle term.
This is when a campus will
have to switch back and forth
between face-to-face instruction
and wholly online instruction.
- [Alexander] Each of these
scenarios would be costly.
Even in the best forecast,
where the pandemic is shorter
and campuses reopen in the
fall, there's no guarantee
that all students and faculty will return.
That means smaller classes
and less revenue for schools.
If the fall semester is online,
Alexander expects the financial
hit to be even more severe
as more students demand tuition breaks.
- We have about 4,400
colleges and universities
in the U.S. all told, and
I could see easily 10%
staring into the abyss
this time next year.
What worries me are, first of all,
private colleges and universities
that, you know, therefore
lack any state support,
but that are not the most highly ranked,
the lower ranked and
the medium ranked ones.
- [Alexander] Dominican
University is a small,
private liberal arts college
located in San Rafael, California.
- We know we're gonna
have some financial hits.
We know we'll have to make
some adjustments to get there,
but we know where we're headed,
and we're really reasonably
well-positioned to manage this.
The place where Dominican
is not as well-positioned,
and it's true of many,
many small colleges,
is we don't have deep pockets.
You know, we have a
really small endowment.
- [Alexander] But small private schools
aren't the only ones at risk.
Some state universities
are in trouble as well.
- I'm also concerned about
public university systems
that are facing similar problems.
For example, you think about Pennsylvania.
- [Alexander] One of the
public systems at risk
is Pennsylvania's State
System of Higher Education,
which is made up of 14
state-owned colleges and universities.
- The challenges of higher education,
public higher education generally,
they're pretty acutely concentrated here.
Obviously, a historic pattern
of declining public investment
has forced universities
to increase tuition
and actually net average price overall,
so those challenges sort of have combined
in our system to produce
the 20% enrollment decrease
since 2010, between 2010 and 2019,
and obviously, as our enrollments go down,
we're in an enrollment-driven industry,
and as a consequence, our
revenues have declined as well.
- [Alexander] If there is
one consensus in higher ed,
it's that online education is here to stay
and that it will only grow in importance.
One company that is uniquely positioned
to understand this trend is Chegg.
Chegg provides online services
for about 60% of American
college students.
- When I went to college
many, many years ago,
my Intro to Business courses
were 300-person lectures
in a giant auditorium.
Not only are those potentially
dangerous right now,
but the reality is, those lend
themselves very, very well
to online learning.
- [Alexander] Last semester,
schools were forced online
out of necessity, but the reality is,
for many students, necessity
may keep them there.
- We have to imagine
that many, many families
are seeing their savings and
investments put into chaos,
those who have those,
some of them are being hit economically
by unemployment or underemployment.
Some of them additionally
are being hit by disease.
- Like a lot of things right now,
what you're seeing is an acceleration.
There's already been a
movement of lots of people
questioning the ROI of going
in for a four-year degree
that, all-in, may cost 250 or $300,000
for people, while they're also not working
and getting a job that entire time.
- [Alexander] More students
online means less revenue
for schools, but Bryan
Alexander is optimistic
that the industry will get creative
and adapt to students' needs.
- Well, for looking at the fall,
and if either of my
scenarios come to pass,
either the toggle term or the long plague
and faculty and staff have to prepare
for a full semester online,
now we have months, not weeks,
we have months to plan, prepare,
shape, and hone the experience.
(pleasant ambient music)